there's a troubling new allegation
against one of pro football's top
quarterbacks two dozen women now accused
desean watson of sexual assault or
misconduct during massage sessions the
newest lawsuit was filed yesterday
watson denies any wrongdoing with any of
the women but he has been sidelined for
more than a year and the nfl is also
investigating adriana diaz has more
in a lawsuit filed against deshaun
watson on monday a woman who was a
massage therapist alleges the 26 year
old arranged two massages for himself at
her apartment in august of 2020. the
lawsuit claims that during the second
massage watson exposed himself and began
performing a lewd act in front of the
masseuse before paying for the massage
and leaving
the accuser also claims she quit massage
therapy after the incident and now
suffers from depression and anxiety
monday's lawsuit is the 24th civil case
filed against watson since march of last
year
i feel a range of emotions
guilt embarrassment
shame
ashley solis was the first accuser to
come forward in 2021 she appeared on an
episode of real sports with bryant
gumbel last month i just feel sad that
anybody had to feel the way that i did
when i was in that room because it's so
scary this year two texas grand juries
declined to indict watson on criminal
complaints related to some of the
allegations
watson played for the houston texans
when accusations were first made against
him the team didn't play him at all in
2021 and traded him to the cleveland
browns after last season these are
serious charges so we're we're looking
at this seriously the nfl declined to
comment to cbs news on the latest
lawsuit rusty hardin is desean watson's
attorney what we've been saying all
along is look let's just take each
individual case on its merits and when
that happens
you find that
they're just not credible for cbs
mornings i'm adriana diaz